Ambient sound: story being read to children
DANA SHERIDAN:
The Cotsen Library
is a wing of rare books
and special collections.
And it's the benefaction
of Lloyd Cotsen,
who was in the class of '50.
And it is over five
centuries worth of books,
original artwork, documents,
manuscripts, toys,
educational objects that are
all related to childhood.
Rare Books is within
Firestone library,
and the Cotsen Gallery
is in Firestone as well.
When Mr. Cotsen donated his
collection to the university,
he also said he wanted
a public gallery
for children and
outreach programming
for children that promote
a love of literacy.
And the result here is
Bookscape, the Bookscape
Gallery, which is
open to the public.
And it is free of charge,
as are all of our programs.
It's a community portal
here at the university.
At night, he sleeps in his
secret hiding place and has--
JOANI ETSKOVITZ: Kids just
have this natural sense
of wonder about everything.
They want to learn,
because they're
genuinely fascinated by it,
because everything is magical.
And I think that when you give
a kid a box of rhinestones,
or a box sparkles, and a
little bit of inspiration--
a story or craft-- it just
excites that sense of wonder.
And I hope that they
carry that wonder
into the rest of their lives,
as well as a love of reading
and creating.
RYAN BUDNICK: I've
learned to never
be surprised by how
incredible these kids are.
They'll astound you
with how much they know,
and how quickly
they'll learn, and what
they're willing to try.
MIRANDA MARRACCINI: It's
great working with the kids.
Sometimes, they come back into
the office and ask what we do.
And kids are always
really interested to hear
about what it is we do in
special collections libraries,
and to see the
books behind glass,
and to know what they're for.
And they're just really
eager to learn about it.
ANDREA IMMEL: One of the
things that really gives us
continuing pleasure is the
fact that sometimes scholars
who have had
fellowships come back
later with their grandchildren
or their children.
And sometimes, the
students who work for us
become scholars who use the
collection for their JPs,
their senior theses.
The synergy is
really a pleasure.
And when I started
in 1995, I never
would have predicted
that we would
have had this kind of success in
fostering what Mr. Cotsen hoped
would happen.
JARED CROOKS: As much as
this is for the children,
at the same time, it's a space
for the students as well,
like a little
hideaway that says,
hey, remember this
when you were a kid?
Remember when you
thought big things,
and you dreamed crazy thoughts?
This is still on campus.
And so I feel like it's
a part of the community,
just as it's a
part of ourselves.
There is some part
of us that's hidden,
and we see that
it's more childlike,
and we can revert
to that safe space.
And I think that this
does for the Princeton
campus what that place in
our heart does for ourselves.
RYAN BUDNICK: We're
just hoping that they
leave with a better love
for knowledge and desire
to seek out new knowledge.
And every once in
awhile, we'll hear
from an alumni of Cotsen
Critix, and they'll just talk
about whatever they're doing.
And it's really incredible to
see that from this program,
they both are getting a
lot and that they go on
to do incredible things.